this is not technically a double header
it was a suspended game that was resumed
so that was under nine inning rules but
this is the second game of the day and
they'll only play seven trevor williams
on the mount for the minutes tonight
jazz chisholm leads off for the marlins
first pitch of the game is grounded down
to first base diving stop by alonso from
his knee throws him out a scintillating
start to this game
first pitch thrown terrific play by
alonso to retire chisholm for the first
down nice play by pete on his toes
beautiful backhand very nicely done
ground ball poked through for a base hit
for lewis brinson
lewis had a couple of days off dealing
with that thumb injury but back with a
knock gonna bring up jesus sanchez
who rips a base hit into right field
brinson's on his way to third
he'll get there the marlins have runners
on the corners two on and two out good
at first base but struggle with the bat
flies this one to shallow left center
bae is out mcneil in baez says i got it
he does and that retires the side edward
cabrera his second major league start
one of the top pitching prospects in all
of minor league baseball 30 overall
according to mlb pipeline
and jonathan vr fly ball pretty deep
left but the ballpark will hold it
here's the 2-2 pitch swinging a ground
ball up the middle knocked down by
cabrera he can't find it it's to the
right of the mount he fires two late to
first and nemo is aboard
[Applause]
runner goes throw is in time
good throw from sandy leone to get
brandon nimmo had his best gear in 2018
when he won 14 ball games and sierra
foul tips it for strike three there's
the first strike out of the knife for
trevor williams
[Applause]
and he takes a fastball for strike three
call
back-to-back strikeouts for trevor
williams to finish off the top of the
second had a hit and an rbi and his only
at bat was also hit by a pitch
cabrera the 0-1 there's a ball lined to
left over brinson leaps and makes the
catch on to the warning track
full extension to make that play
back to first base retreats conforto one
out second inning
conforto off of first cabrera deals a
breaking ball let's hit on the ground to
jazz feeds it to second and back over to
first a double play
all right edward cabrera rolls another
double play ball works out of trouble in
the second
[Applause]
fly ball deep to right center off the
bat of cabrera but nimmo gives ground
and makes the play emma was playing very
shallow with the pitcher up had to go a
long way to get that to retire cabrera
for the first time first pitch to jd
davis fastball line to right center base
hit sanchez goes to get it tosses it
back in lead off single for davis
who brings it home
and gets a ground ball and wouldn't you
know it six to four to three oh boy
another double play
i think because of the shift that one
actually goes six to five to three
because that was issan diaz with the
shift but
a twin killing nonetheless fourth inning
lewis brinson leads off against trevor
williams
up and in and he got him
three pitches and williams disposes of
brinson and that's his third strike out
of the night he's just been pounding the
strike zone from the first pitch
and he strikes out sanchez with a high
fastball
back-to-back strikeouts for williams
six pitches two strikeouts
up the middle from vr and he's got a
base hit to start the mets in the fourth
hard turn and he falls down and
chisholm didn't realize it until too
late had chisholm turn quicker and
realized that vr had lost his footing he
might have had a chance to get him going
back in the first
and he hits one past the mound who's
gonna play it it's gonna be rojas and he
has no play but he's got vr who made it
too big a turn around
second great play by rojas hanging on to
the ball base running mistake by vr and
he is tagged out for the first down of
the inning that is just a very petty
play by
rojas and he gets alonzo to chase
strikeout number one in the ball game
for cabrera two away in the fourth
and confer smacks it's a deep right
field forget it into the second deck
michael can afford a little ball in the
mitch league two nothing number 10 for
conforto and he just whacked it so fresh
off his big hit in the ninth inning
earlier today
conforto builds on it
with an impressive home run to put the
mets on top
now baez lines the base in into center
field
picked up quickly by sierra and he holds
baez to a
single now mcneil smacks one in the
center for a base hit byers is going to
go first to third and it gets on by
follows around third he's coming home
it's an rbi double for jeff mcneal and
it's 3-0
hits in the inning three runs at home
sierra didn't take the best route to the
ball and that enabled bias to score all
the way from the first
ground ball that's bobbled by vr and
then he can't pick it up
rough 20-minute stretch here for
jonathan vr marlins have
a leadoff man on here in the fifth
2-1 pitch to miggy ground ball up the
middle off of
williams and rojas will reach sandy
leone to second
payoff pitch is sent out to right and
this is going to get down for extra
bases
conforto digs it out leon scores
miggy is
going to stop at third
rbi double for jesus aguilar and the
marlins are on the board
diaz hits one back to loop he's got it
comes home ezekiel the first double play
side retired
oh wow
a shot back to loop he found that little
pearl and turned it into a one two three
double plays side retired he's got a
good arm and always seems to pitch well
against the marlins
[Applause]
there's base hit for brinson
his second of the game
his first start in a few days
o2 to leone
struck him out
high fast ball from lugo to get leon for
the second out of the inning this will
be the eighth pitch of the at-bat to
sierra
struck him out
went to the curve ball and lugo finds
his way out of trouble in the sixth
inning with back-to-back strikeouts of
leon
and sierra to strand two in scoring
position three outs to get for diaz
bidding for his 27th save 02 to alfaro
struck him out not even close to
catching up with that slider mazika
makes the toss and that's the second out
[Applause]
he struck him out and the ball game is
over 101 on the last fastball from edwin
diaz to fan jazz chisholm and the mets
win two games in one day
you